übermorgen ist es soweit schicksalswahl
in sachsen anhalt im bundesland von
ministerpräsident reiner haseloff
bekannt aus dem disney klassiker 101
sachsen anhaltiner stimmt nicht es sind
um ganz genau zu sein
2,2 millionen sachsen anhaltiner das ist
jetzt im vergleich auch nicht viel
trotzdem wird der sonntag super spannend
es ist nämlich der letzte große
stimmungstest vor der bundestagswahl
und wenn da die afg vielleicht doch noch
vor der cdu landet dann ist natürlich
alarm auch für armin laschet der sich
persönlich in den sachsen anhalt
wahlkampf rhein geworfen hat hier sein
überraschender auftritt dort nennt
kuckuck da ist ja noch mal einen
wunderschönen günther ja von mir auch wo
kam denn problem die menschen in
ostdeutschland sind ja ich sag mal so
nicht direkt am ins kraut mehr west als
flasche geht gar nicht also selber mal
gesagt das ist ein zitat
er hat da eine sehr überschaubare
fanbase auch weil sich die cdu in den
neuen ländern halt eher friedrich merz
gewünscht hatte bruder markus söder oder
irgendwen außer armin hier stimme der
basis
würdet ihr euch einen termin mit armin
laschet wünschen im wahlkampf jeden tag
ein zwei auftritte der geschichte wegen
der geschichte sie will nicht mal den
namen laschet aussprechen weil das im
osten unglück bringen wenn man dem laut
sagt zum glück zum glück hat väterchen
haseloff dann noch einen laschet fan
gefunden aufgetrieben und direkt vor
seiner staatskanzlei platziert und das
wirkte insgesamt sehr natürlich finde
ich sie ist extra hier geblieben und hat
ihre massage verschoben damit wir
kriegen ja haben sie es noch dass der
arminia künftig muss auch eine massage
süß oder später hat sie noch ausgestellt
die frau dachte er wäre andy borg egal
hauptsache autogramm reiner haseloff
muss am sonntag ganz allein armin
laschet ihr und die cdu retten wenn das
einer schafft diese rettungsmission dann
der hasselhoff hase läuft ein wirklich
sehr beliebter ministerpräsident in
einem bundesland über das die meisten
von uns viel zu wenig wissen
hier mal eine kleine landeskunde alles
wissenswerte über sachsen anhalt sachsen
anhalt ist das bundesland durch das man
fährt wenn man zum beispiel von hannover
nach berlin fährt das war alles
wissenswerte über sachsen anhalt
heute also wirklich ich bin sprachlos
das war ja bösartig verkürzt dargestellt
sachsen anhalt ist so viel mehr als
sachsen durchfahrt der praktikant der
diesen film gerade nach meinen
anweisungen geschnitten hat der wird
morgen gefeiert
versprochen sachsen anhalt hat seit der
wende eine unglaubliche transformation
durchgemacht und viel erreicht ganz
ehrlich die arbeitslosenquote ist zum
beispiel niedriger als die von hamburg
tatsache noch regiert reiner haseloff
damit einer sogenannten kenia koalition
aber nach der wahl am sonntag hat er
wohl alle möglichen optionen heißt es im
gespräch ist unter anderem die
sogenannte deutschland koalition oder
simbabwe sind waffe mit cdu spd grünen
und fdp aber um sich das vorzustellen
muss man wahrscheinlich drogen aus dem
waffe nehmen
haseloffs großer vorteil am sonntag ist
er der kandidat den man kennt wirklich
war
die meinungsforscher konnten für die
fünf anderen keine beliebtheitswerte
ermitteln weil kaum einer wusste ja die
sind haseloff ist quasi der einzige star
sagen dir diese gesichter etwas der
seite lasse
da ist das ist nicht leicht das ist
reiner haseloff der minister von 600 ha
laschet haseloff die kammer leicht
verwechseln die beiden nicht nur einen
meter dazwischen reiner haseloff hat im
gegensatz zu ein paar anderen in seiner
cdu-fraktion jede kooperation mit der
afg glasklar ausgeschlossen jede ist
eine wichtige botschaft angesichts von
24 prozent für die alternative in
umfragen also für einen afd
landesverband den der verfassungsschutz
im visier hat und der mit dem slogan
wirbt sachsen anhalt aber normal
tja für rund ein viertel der wähler in
sachsen-anhalt ist es normal
rechtsextreme zu wählen
eine offene völkisch nationale partei
geführt von spitzenkandidat oliver
kirchner dessen persönlicher referent
war früher mitglied der sogenannten
heimattreuen deutschen jugend hdj
sondern hat fähnlein fieselschweif für
neonazis seit 2009 verboten ja nicht das
zeltlager gerade so sehen könnte man bei
hdj dass die auch gut weg lassen
trotzdem ging spitzenkandidat kirchner
gar nicht daran seinen referenten
patrick hat zu feuern
trotz unvereinbarkeitsbestimmungen die
gut ausgebildet sind und die sich für
uns engagieren wollen diese chance nicht
ein und welche geschichte die haben das
kann man gerne mit den gesprächen
untereinander aber ich wusste ich weiß
dass die die presse angeht berlino
jedoch den scheiß anwender alles neonazi
war unser patrick ist solide ausgebildet
worden von den nazis warum soll ich den
feuern
preisfrage hat die afc in sachsen anhalt
so viele fans obwohl sie sich immer mehr
radikalisiert oder weil gott ist das
alles deprimierend kann man nicht mal
irgendwas lustiges senden wenn ich
bundeskanzler wenn dann wird oft
deutschland ganz oben auf der
tagesordnung der deutschen politik
stehen
wenn ich bundeskanzler das hat gut getan
irgendwie dachte ich wir wären schon
weiter aber jetzt streitet deutschland
schon wieder über den osten weil
ausgerechnet marco wanderwitz der
ostbeauftragte der bundesregierung so
sinngemäß gesagt hat teil von denen
kannst du abschreiben reaktion natürlich
riesenaufregung reden wir darüber mit
christian ehring der sich seit jahren
intensiv mit dem stand der deutschen
einheit beschäftigt ja wirklich ein
herzensthema von mir und es ist so
schade dass wir in der kommunikation
immer dieselben fehler machen gerade wir
als westdeutsche erwäge wir müssen ja
nicht aufhören aber die ostdeutschen zu
reden wie über so problembären mal
respekt haben für die biografien der
menschen auf augenhöhe kommunizieren
statt von oben herab den richtigen ton
treffen das ganz wichtig kann sich alles
nachlesen
in meinem neuen buch christian ehring
der aussie flüsterer und der titel ist
auf augenhöhe ganz genau
ja ich bin wirklich wütend auf diesen
wanderwitz du kannst doch als ost
beauftragt da nicht ernsthaft sagen wir
haben es mit menschen zu tun die
teilweise in einer form diktatur
sozialisiert sind dass sie auch nach 30
jahren nicht in der demokratie
angekommen sind
nur ein geringer teil der afg wähler
seien potenziell rückholbar ich meine
gut da könnte man jetzt auch im
klassischen wutbürger jargon anmerken
das wird man ja wohl noch sagen dürfen
nein eben nicht der ostbeauftragte
vertritt in der groko die interessen des
ostens in einem kabinett in dem übrigens
kein einziger aus deutscher minister mir
sitzt ja drei saarländer aber kein haus
deutscher das kann doch nicht wahr sein
gleich drei aus dem saarland diesem
franzosen puff diesem legendären ins
gebiet aber kein einziger aus
deutschland hat sie haben ja recht
auch sämtliche kanzler kandidaten und
kandidatinnen sind wessis der osten ist
schon unterrepräsentiert
das ist doch kein grund völkische
rassisten zu wählen immerhin ist die
kanzlerin aus dem osten aber ich sage
mal so man wird in den neuen ländern in
naher zukunft wahrscheinlich keine
plätze nach ebenen lässt waren das volk
nichts an seinem
vermeintlichen vertreter scharf
beobachtet und dann gibt es auch noch
links ab das ist aber jetzt schon wieder
ein bisschen diese arrogante spöttische
ton hr
wir müssen wirklich lernen endlich
miteinander zu reden statt übereinander
und vor seiner wahl im osten eben nicht
zittern sondern endlich mal das positive
nach vorne stellen ich bin gerade auf
tour mit einem power point vortrag
positives über sachsen anhalt statt
immer nur um 24% afd sage ich und 76
prozent wählen nicht afd positiv oder
hier quedlinburg das ist damit
wunderschön
sachsen anhalt hat die höchste dichte an
unesco welterbe stätten und wussten sie
95 prozent des deutschen marktes kommen
aus sachsen anhalt und wo wurde die
luftpumpe erfunden
1649 in magdeburg haid und was man
unbedingt mal probieren sollte ist der
weltweit einmalige milbenkäse aus durch
witz haring bitte sie mit käse aus
würchwitz das letzte an sich doch
ausgedacht eben nicht einfach mal
hinfahren und sich das alles angucken
es gibt so viel zu entdecken in sachsen
anhalt ach man kann da auch regelrecht
urlaub machen
keine ahnung ich war noch nie da
christian ehring
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
los los du scheiße fährt haye